welcome back I wish you guys could smell
it in here Villa Azure combines the
flavors of France with the party of
South Beach and the liveliness of Cote
de Azure all within the Grand Canal
shops at the Venetian and joining us
today to talk all things dinner party we
have to coverage of fif and Chef Sani
habash thank you guys so much for being
here I just asked you if you could come
every day for us because it smells so
good you guys it is smells good okay it
really does fantastic let's talk about
the restaurant I'm going to start over
here tell us a little bit about the vibe
and the energy and the entertainment so
we bring the lazur to Las Vegas because
it is a great concept for the people
that don't want to go out to nightclubs
that expect a nice dinner with a show
with an energy Vibe so that's Villas or
amazing food amazing Ambience amazing
service in a beautiful environment uh
what could you expect it's a live music
live band every night Wednesday to
Sunday then at 10 pm DJ starts picking
up the the vibe the mood and then
everyone goes crazy then it's a party
and we're looking at some photos that's
so beautiful in there but the food is
what makes it extra beautiful Chef I'll
bring you another conversation over here
what are you making sure it smells
absolutely we're doing the patella mule
uh in the pecorino wheel so we have our
house made pasta we do all our pastas
in-house we make everything here so we
cook those noodles in our in our little
sauce here it's a creamy sauce with
mushrooms I don't think it's a little
bit
that's that's the addition so we scrape
out this cheese wheel we uh flambe the
cognac inside add the pasta into there
and it's it's just an amazing dish wow
this looks incredible and in addition to
this I mean the menu goes on and on can
you tell us about some of the other
items in front of us here it's also
beautiful sure absolutely
um so we do we like to center around
some sharing plates so up front we have
the burrato with the truffles uh the one
pound burrata especially imported for us
we do it with little pistachio butter a
little salad some croutons so you could
dip into their colpacho beef with
arugula parmesan pine nuts a caper and
black pepper aioli Hamachi Crudo with
the Yuzu sauce and some chili chili oil
just gorgeous little dishes but you know
also another ravioli romance a very
south of France dish very very much
popular throughout south of France so
that we have that on the menu as well
well I've always wanted to go to France
but now I don't have to because you're
bringing all the taste and flavors here
and you can't have food without some
drinks so we're running out of time here
but I want to get the cocktails in so
tell us a little bit about these so uh
my name is Robert I'm the mixologist
with villazor and I wanted to match the
energy and the vibrancy of the food with
the cocktail menu so I went with the
smoked old-fashioned with Patron Alto
tequila we also have another tequila
cocktail here with the swan song and
then we have a dragon fruit Martini well
this all looks amazing we're going to
show more of this on social media
because this needs a moment it all needs
a moment but I love this glass you guys
thank you so much for being here be sure
to go get a taste of villa Azure you
won't be disappointed